you your team is just phenomenal to
watch it has been an absolute delight
I'm wondering what it's been like for
you
oh it's been you know it's been great
then it's been a fun tournament so far
you know obviously not a big win last
night for us
and just you know it's fun to be a part
of this team and we look forward to
another another challenge and
opportunity on Sunday to go out there
and get a gold medal sure and and in
terms of preparation for that how do you
how are you taking in the the
Netherlands Sweden match obviously you
know these teams one in particular but
how are you guys taking that one in will
be will probably get together tonight to
watch back at the hotel and we I think
some of our coaches will will go to the
games in sochi aaron leone but will will
enjoy tonight watch the game find out
who we take on on Sunday and then
tomorrow we'll start preparing for
whichever opponent we have all right so
since the hotel has been a subject of
conversation certainly in the UK have
you checked in to this hotel yet ELISA
we just got in about 10 minutes ago okay
did you see any of the English team
checking out at that point in time
ELISA I did not see anybody know so they
staggered the check-in and the checkout
process they did that how did you how do
you and your teammates find out about
what's going on in the outside world of
what's being said about you and your
team
um I have been off social social media
since we left the state so we keep a
pretty tight bubble over here but oh
yeah usually people you know find things
out one way or another so you haven't
heard about me owning Piers Morgan's ass
in just three words on Twitter you
haven't heard about that then Alyssa I
actually have not heard of the hi gosh
well it's one of my proudest
accomplishments I'm a 50 year old man
I've got three children I've got a great
life but this unfortunately for me is
one of my top five achievements Alyssa
let me hear it okay so here's the deal
so you know obviously how Ally
it's how the the everything went down
yesterday and how you know you guys went
up one nothing and then one one and then
Alex Morgan scores the goal to go up to
1 and in sips the tea you saw that right
I actually have not seen that not oh my
gosh yes you sip sip the tea with her
pinky extended and Piers Morgan made it
seeps put out dope not tea making it
seem like she's smoking so I responded
it's tea dope I know you know that's all
I wanted I just you know wanted to bring
that to your attention so when you are
no look I thought in all honesty I I
think this whole conversation about the
way you and your team or your teammates
have celebrated has been way off the
mark and I'm not again I'm not just
saying that because you're on the phone
line right here because in all honesty I
don't think I don't hear that about men
I don't hear that about the guys the way
that they celebrate ELISA and I'm
wondering what your thought on that
subject would be
I mean it's just any time you can
celebrate celebrate a goal it's you know
we we've been through you know a lot
together as a team and a goal is an
opportunity to celebrate together as
that team you know all eleven players on
the field and you know are twelve others
on the sidelines so anytime we can score
a goal you take an you take the
opportunity you know take it in the
moment
celebrate with each other and celebrate
the moment together and just enjoy it
that's all it is it's just a way for us
to to you know be together as a team and
and come together and enjoy the enjoy
the time that we've put together well
and I noticed that as soon as you made
the big save on on the penalty kick that
you were not up for anything other than
continuing play I wonder what was going
through your mind at that moment Alyssa
well technically as a goalkeeper I only
am allowed to hold the ball for so and
I'd already been getting yelled at to
move my pace along by the referee so
didn't want to take any chances of
giving giving up an indirect free kick
after that so she's trying to move on
with the play and I get going
did did in any way shape or form did did
Steph hauntin tip her hand a little bit
to you that you pick up anything prior
to the penalty kick
you know just tried to get be in the
moment just kind of get you hope you can
get a feel for it and just letting
things take over from there and
fortunately I was able able to go the
right way and get get a hand through it
and keep possession of it so that's you
know just a happy that it worked out in
my favor sure a few more minutes left
with Alyssa Nair u.s. women's national
team goalkeeper are you aware of the
impact that your team is having back
here in the States on jersey sales is
that at all
obviously you know the business aspect
of this might not have pierced the
bubble that you have created for
yourself are you where I've heard rumors
that it might be that it's just that the
jersey has done pretty well
back in the state number one number one
selling Jersey men's or women's ever
sold on nike.com in one single season
Wow Alyssa that's incredible I mean
we've always had we we take a lot of
pride in the fans that we have we
appreciate all the love and support from
all of our fans who have traveled here
to Europe and you know back in the
States and to hear things like that it
just you know it speaks volumes for you
know the support that we have and we
appreciate every single person and we we
feel the love we feel the support and it
means a lot to us
it's been amazing what was the first
jersey you ever bought first Jersey I
ever bought i think i mighta had a me
hand Jersey back in the day
when I was a kid growing up okay did you
use money babysitting for Dan Patrick
and his children to purchase that Jersey
Alyssa hey I worked hard I worked hard
babysitting for Dan Patrick's kid yeah I
saved up that money but no I think this
was this is a Christmas present for my
parent how was Dan as somebody paying
was he cheap did he what was the rate
that you had from Dan Alyssa you
remember I don't remember the exact rate
but he was he was he was good he was a
generous guy okay he was good it was it
was fine I doubt you know because Dan is
definitely on the up and up I just
wanted to make sure you know yeah now
Dan's a good guy here's the crazy thing
is that his kids are now babysitting
mine in Los Angeles that's a fact
how did you guys celebrate Alex Morgan's
birthday last night last one for you
Alyssa we got back to the hotel and our
wonderful chef who has been travelling
with us for the month had a funfetti
birthday cake waiting for us in the
lobby so that was the perfect way to get
back to the hotel and celebrate does it
fit with the with the training regimen a
little funfetti at this point in time or
what do you say we you know special
moments and occasions require or allow
us to have you know a little bit of a
like a sheep slice so we just made our
nutritionist look the other way for a
second well Alyssa let me just say it
again it has been an absolute delight
watching you go to work and the rest of
your teammates go to work and represent
this country the way that you are
representing us it has just been amazing
and I speak for millions of people when
I say thank you for what you've done so
far and go get Netherlands or Sweden on
Sunday thank you so much I really
appreciate it appreciate all your
support
thanks for having me on and I hope
you're as excited for Sunday as we are I
am there's no doubt about it Alissa and
and it's a you know obviously the whole
country is gonna be settled in you got
fourth of July coming up after today's
match to find out who you're playing and
obviously Sunday so it'll be great
awesome thank you so much you bet Alyssa
let's chat again soon that's listen
there u.s. women's national team
goalkeeper former Dan Patrick babysitter
for more of the Rich Eisen show tune -
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV for free
on BR live or download the Rich Eisen
show app